welcome back well i've been requested to
do uh several problems by our friend
akash so i thought i would keep doing
them i'm skipping around a little bit
because i think i did all of them it
would just generate you know too many
videos but um i encourage all of y'all
to to let me know if there's if you feel
that there's something that i might have
missed but anyway uh i'm just going
through some of the problems he gave so
this one and i actually almost find it
funny because they use such formal
language for for something that's
actually a pretty intuitive concept well
they say use the monotonicity theorem to
find where the given function is
increasing and when it is decreasing
monotonicity
mono i can't even monotonicity
monoto
monotonicity function
theorem
makes sound very serious
well all the monotonicity theorem at
least
if i'm remembering
things properly all it says is when when
the derivative is positive
when f prime of x is greater than zero
your function is increasing
and when the derivative is negative
your function is decreasing
and why am i kind of
you know disparaging of this well it's
you know what's the derivative the
derivative is the slope and you learned
in algebra one that if the slope is
positive if the slope is positive the
the the graph of the line is increasing
and if the slope is negative the graph
of the line is decreasing and the only
thing that's different now is that you
know this function isn't necessarily a
line it's it's a function so it could be
a curve but having a positive slope
means that the value of the function is
increasing for every change in x there's
a positive change in y and similarly a
negative slope says that for every
change in x no matter how small there's
a negative change in y so there's
nothing fancy here but let's see they
gave some examples so they want us to
use the this theorem to find where the
given function is increasing when it is
decreasing so the first function they
give is f of x
is equal to 3x plus 3.
well what's the derivative of this f
prime of x
is equal to three
well
for any value of x this is positive
right f prime of x is positive for all
values of x so this thing using the
monotonicity theorem is positive
sorry is increasing for all values of x
and you could have done that in the
ninth grade how well you would have said
well you know this is a this is the
slope slope y-intercept the slope is
three
so this is an increasing function the
function will look something like this
the y-intercept is 3 and its slope is 3
so this function looks something like
that and so it's increasing over from
you know you could say from minus
infinity
to positive infinity over that interval
if you wanted to be fancy but
this is really just a lot of fancy
terminology to to talk about i think
something fairly straightforward
anyway
the next one looks a little bit more
interesting
h of z
h of z
is equal to
z to the fourth
over four
minus
and i hope i'm reading this right 4
z to the third
[Music]
over 6.
so let's see if we can figure out when
this is increasing and when this is
decreasing when the function is
increasing or decreasing
so what's the derivative of this
h prime of z
is equal to let's see four
well this will cancel out so it's z to
the third
right four z to the third over four so
it's z to the third
minus
let's see 3 times 4 is 12 z squared
but
12 z squared over 6 so it's 2
z squared
and so we just have to figure out when
is this function greater than zero and
when is this function less than zero and
and to figure this out we really just
have to break out our algebra toolkit to
figure out what one when does this
function equal zero
so let's set
z cubed minus two z
squared is equal to zero we could factor
let's see we could factor out a z
squared
and then we have z
minus two is equal to zero
so we know that either z squared is
equal to 0
or
z minus 2 is equal to 0 so the point at
which the derivative is 0
so h prime
of 0 is equal to 0 and h prime of two
and that's just our calcula our our
our
algebra two we're so h prime of two is
equal to zero
and so we just have to figure out what
happens in the interval maybe when we're
below zero
uh between zero and two and then above
two so what is the derivative so
when we're below zero let's just take a
a
a point let's say
h prime of negative one
h prime
of negative one
is equal to what that is equal to
negative one to the third is negative
one
minus two
times negative one squared well negative
one squared is just positive one
right so it's minus two
right
so it equals minus three
okay let's take a point in between these
two well one is in between them so let's
just take
h prime of one is equal to one
minus
two
one
minus let me make sure i'm doing that
right one minus two right because it's
one squared so it equals negative one
h prime of one
and then what happens when we go
of z values greater than twos let's try
three
h prime
of three
is equal to what h prime of 3 is equal
to
27
what's minus 2 times 9 it's equal to 9
right
18 right h right so it's positive
so what do we know we know that
and and
in all fairness this is kind of this is
this is kind of an interesting problem
because the derivative
is negative so if if we were to
if we were to draw
the derivative of this
what are the interesting points it's
zero
this is so that's the x axis
that's zero and then we had 2.
and this i'm going to draw the
derivative i'm not drawing the actual
function
because the monotonicity theorem we care
about when the derivative is positive or
negative
so what this tells us is
is that the derivative it was negative
when we're to the left of zero right
because we just took a test point
because we know it's zero here
but then what happened it's not like it
got positive then it went back negative
again when we tried the derivative at
once it probably does something like
this
it probably
does something like
this
and then
now what would it be
let's see
and it goes up
at 2 where it's greater than zero
right right right right right i was
confusing myself for a second right so
the derivative
it probably right it starts but it never
goes above right there so the derivative
probably has a bit of a
you could you could it probably has a
bit of a maximum point there or
something this is the derivative
remember that's how i was confusing
myself and then it probably flips around
and then goes above there
but from the monotonicity theorem what
do we care about we care about the
intervals where the derivative is uh
positive and the derivative is negative
so the derivative is positive
for
all of these values for
z is greater than 2
right so we could say you know using the
monotonicity theorem
this function is increasing when z is
greater than 2. so let me write that
increasing
when z is greater than two
and then we can say that the function is
decreasing
function we could say flat or decreasing
right because the f the slope of the
function is zero right here and remember
this is the graph of the derivative so
we could say flat or decreasing when z
is less than two
and you know depending up you you
normally do consider flat monotonic
kind of in one direction so you could
say monotonic increasing would still
include something that kind of flattens
out
well anyway
i'm pushing 10 minutes and i don't think
i have time for the next problem which i
might do the next video but hopefully
you found that a little bit helpful and
not too confusing i will see you in the
next video